hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on fortnight again for
another video and today we're gonna be
talking about the vending machine it is
the new item added into fortnight and
basically if you're not aware these are
vending machines that are scattered
throughout the map that come with random
loot if you deliver enough materials to
it so we're gonna be talking about where
to find them and then some tips on when
finding or gathering these types of
materials and then getting the inventing
machines so let's get started so first
up there are tons of locations are on
the map with vending machines and
they're also an indifferent in the sense
that they give different loot every time
first up huge mega shout out to the
amazing people over a fortnight Intel
for providing this image on screen of
most of the locations of the vending
machines this link the link to this
image will be on their website in the
description below if you do want to go
check that out for yourself so huge
shout out to those guys I'll leave
credit in the description now there you
can now they even say on their website
that this is not a definitive guide as
there are probably other locations they
are still missing but they will
constantly be updating this picture
until they're fully completed so keep an
eye out for that later in the future as
you can see there are two possible
vending machine locations in retail
Pleasant loot lake tilted and
technically in tomato if but you're
gonna need a walk a bit of a distance at
least for Pleasant the locations I found
were by the gas station and the soccer
field for retail it was the grocery
store market with all the food shelves
everywhere near the taco stand and the
location and Tilted was by behind the
clock tower in that little building at
the bottom there is another location and
tilted and retail going based off the
image but I couldn't find them in the
hour I spent searching I don't know if
it was because I'm just blind as [ __ ] or
because they just didn't spawn and I got
super unlucky which is usually what
happens most of the time when I do these
videos so I decided that I just would
rather tell you the rough the location
and it seems to be near the water tower
at retail and then the tall grey
building in Tilted which probably makes
the most sense these areas will be
giving you the best advantage and
getting a better vending machine since
there is two of them at possible but do
keep in mind that every location will
have a vending machine in the clip shown
I go to the gas station at pleasant and
find one and that gives me green items
but when I go back next game it's not
there so obviously keep that in mind not
every location will have a vending
machine during the match and it could be
their next match just maybe not at that
one next thing to note is rarity each
eventing machine is also random on what
rarity
but it will also have the rarity of
items to help you understand it goes
like this a vending machine that is gray
is going to be costing 100 of each
material that being wood brick and metal
and it will have great items if the
vending machine has a green color on the
front it's going to be giving green
items and it's going to be about 200
material if it's a blue vending machine
on the front it's going to have blue
items and it's going to be 300 material
a purple is going to have 400 material
and a gold will be 500 now in terms of
the items this could range from pretty
much anything in the game I've seen a
heavy shotgun come out of a purple as
well as a slurp juice I've even seen
impulses and a campfire come out of a
blue one and a trap come out of a green
one so beta pretty much anything that
you can think of in the game and I have
yet to find a gold one I'm assuming
those are pretty rare but I'm assuming
those have are probably going to have
jug jugs some scars and maybe a rocket
launcher
I have heard reports on reddit that
someone did find a chug chug in their
vending machine so that is definitely a
possibility but just to explain it again
just in case the vending machine will
only have one rarity type that being
grey green blue purple or gold and
Nevermore in the same specific vending
machine it will only have gold items it
will never have gold and purple and then
the vending machine might have one
weapon and it might have three at all
it's all completely random in this clip
one of my vending machines had all
suppressed SMGs for every single
material but in the other one across the
street at the gas station this one had a
tach shotgun hunting rifle and a trap
it's entirely random on the location of
the vending machine the rarity of items
it has and how many it will carry so you
just have to get very lucky with this
other bits of info is that the vending
machine cannot be destroyed which is
amazing news so people cannot grief you
and [ __ ] you out of a vending machine
usually I'm assuming if that was the
case people would just grab the item
especially if it's a gold one grab the
scar grab the chug-chug or whatever they
needed and then get on their way and
destroy the vending machine so no one
else can get the goodies another real
nice tip although even though it's
pretty much random if you find it is if
you get a llama that's going to give you
500 material each pretty much for wood
brick and metals you're guaranteed to
get every single thing from the gold
vending machine if you happen to find it
within a location near you but that's
all completely random of course in
llamas there's only three of them
throughout the map and they're all
obviously random based off of location
so they could be anywhere
I myself have not found a llama near a
vending machine and I have also not
found a llama in a very long time I've
probably only found two of them and that
was about last week so like I said these
are pretty random also watch out for
campers nearby obviously with the
iteration of the remote explosives
people are trapping or booby trapping
llamas and supply drops so definitely be
trapping these when you're walking
around a vending machine please be
careful and look around if you see
anything around that's really odd if
there's type of like a brick that seems
to be around the vending machine if it's
glowing it's probably a remote explosive
so back off or shoot it because
obviously the vending machine cannot be
destroyed so if you shoot it it's not
going to do anything it'll just blow up
the area around it and then you will
also know that there's somebody nearby
so be on the lookout for that and then
lastly you will have to wait for the
specific material if you want that item
to come by because it Scrolls through
the material in my experience the green
vending machine that I found had a tak
hunting rifle in a trap I had enough
metal so I wanted to get the trap but it
was at the it just recently passed the
trap so I had to wait for it to go to
the tack scroll over to the hunting
rifle and scroll over back to the trap
you can't just deposit whatever material
you want it goes by and it's on a timer
but obviously it loops back around you
just have to wait longer and that's
about it guys just to recap again just
in case anybody was confused these
vending machines are entirely random in
terms of the location the rarity and the
amount of weapons they will have whether
that be one through three
make sure to gather enough material
since its range can be from 100 to 500
materials depending on the vending
machine you find and watch out for
nearby players to ambush you like I said
if you want to see the location for most
of the vending machines in the game
check the description to for tonight
Intel they have a vid they have a image
with tons of the locations majority of
them being in retail Lou Lake tilted
tomato and Pleasant all that good stuff
so if you definitely want to find a
vending machine definitely hit up those
nearby locations but lastly we're going
to end the video today with my overall
thoughts and my comparisons that if it
should be in the game or not or if it
makes any sense
I think the vending machines are a good
iteration into the game it's really nice
that you can basically get any weapon
throughout the game without having to go
search for chests and hope and pray that
you'll find one it's really nice
especially if you have enough
Tyrael obviously like I said it's random
so a mayor may you may or may not even
get a decent weapon you might just get
stuck with a gray SMG like I did and
then get [ __ ] out of luck for it and
hopefully the chest will come by or you
could get lucky and find a gold one and
get a gold scar right off the start of
the game which is absolutely amazing and
really helping you to get that victory
royale I think these are really nice
they're definitely not overpowered at
all
they obviously these locations are
random so there is an a set location so
not every single vending machine and
pleasent is going to be a guaranteed
purple because like I said I had a gray
in a green before so it obviously swaps
and then sometimes the vending machines
aren't even there which is really nice
to know so the devs did an amazing job
of making sure that this thing is
balanced and I'm very glad this thing is
in the game and I'm also very hyped to
find more of these throw out than my
matches but let me know what you guys
think about the new vending machine
hopefully you guys do find some tell me
what you guys found it in yours like I
said the highest thing that I could find
was a heavy shotgun and a slurp before I
got gunned down because I just wanted to
taunt the guy that was shooting me
because I had no weapons but sadly that
was all I could find if you guys did
find a goal and definitely let me know
what you guys did find in there to be
awesome to see but that's going to be
the end of the video today guys like the
video if you guys did enjoy review does
help me out subscribe if you're new I'm
gonna be covering a lot more for tonight
content and stuff like that so
definitely keep on the lookout for that
in terms of guides and tips for the new
types of weapons are an any type of item
like the vending machine and other stuff
like that and anything else that comes
in the future of this game my two most
recent video is going to be on screen if
you guys don't want to check that out I
believe there are guides for the past
weapons so definitely go and check those
out if you guys want to learn more tips
on how to use those weapons correctly
I'd be really appreciated if you did
and with that guys hope you have a great
rest of your day and peace out